since 1977 a galaxy far far away has
been gifting our universe with some of
the most innovative sci-fi action we've
ever seen plus some other movies that
aren't as memorable all of these films
are packed with details that even star
wars fans some of the most committed
movie viewers on our planet took decades
to find there's still unearthing details
that have lain hidden for years like an
old jedi knight in exile waiting for the
next generation to track him down
occasionally they get confirmation that
their hunches were correct but sometimes
they're just left to guess the elaborate
world and history that make up the star
wars franchise plus its aforementioned
dedicated fans make it ripe for easter
eggs it's so influential that there are
even star wars easter eggs in other
movies in 10 years we could still be
talking about easter eggs none of us
have yet spotted in the most recent
entries in the franchise for the moment
though here are two star wars easter
eggs years in the making did you notice
them
in the empire strikes back c-3po tells
han solo that he's having trouble
communicating with the mainframe of the
millennium falcon because
i don't know where your ship learned to
communicate but it has the most peculiar
dialect when the movie came out in 1980
this seemed like a throwaway line
designed to undermine c-3po's
occasionally oversized faith in his own
translation abilities which he brings up
as often as possible but the true story
behind that comment was revealed nearly
four decades later thanks to solo a star
wars story the prequel charting han's
early adventures from imperial trooper
to smuggler to rebel we also met the
younger version of his longtime frenemy
landau carissian and lando's droid
navigator the acerbic l337 unlike most
droids l337 is self-made literally she
pulled herself together from components
of different droids she's more sentient
and opinionated than most droids
including c-3po and r2d2 ultimately l337
dies in battle after freeing droids
being used to slave mining labor on
kessel lando and kira upload her
consciousness into the millennium falcon
and she helps a gang navigate safe
passage away from the planet back to
empire when c-3po plugs into the falcon
he's actually talking to l337 because
she's made up of so many droids it would
make sense that she speaks in a unique
dialect that even language scholar c3po
doesn't understand solo screenwriters
lawrence kazdin and jonathan kasden
confirmed this link in an interview for
film jonathan explained that they wanted
to make l337 a part of the original star
wars in ways that fans couldn't predict
in an effort to quote enrich both the
past and present to the franchise
once you know the entire star wars story
you understand that although yoda looks
like a distant relative of the critters
and gremlins he's actually the most
powerful big eared green alien in the
galaxy you and luke skywalker could be
forgiven for making this mistake based
on yoda's first appearance in the
franchise and the empire strikes back
during their first encounter luke
doesn't quite understand that yoda is
the jedi master he's looking for he just
sees a weird-looking lunch stealing
erratic swamp creature luke is also put
off by yoda's humble hut in the swamp
but that hut hints at yoda's past in the
2004 book inside the worlds of star wars
trilogy the ultimate guide to the
incredible locations of episodes four
five and six there's a cutaway picture
of yoda's hut fans have pointed out that
the walls look like metal coated in mud
and vines which led some to guess that
yoda lives in the same ship he crashed
when the empire strikes back came out in
1980 it wasn't clear how yoda ended up
on dagobah it wasn't until a deleted
scene in revenge of the sith that we saw
yoda landing on the planet on the run
from darth sidious and the newly
established empire yoda's hut and the
ship in that deleted scene don't exactly
match up but we know yoda is adept at
manipulating heavy pieces of metal so
it's certainly possible that he
incorporated parts of the ship when
building his hut picturing the once
powerful jedi grand master salvaging
parts of his escape craft to construct a
hut in the swamp is a sad reminder of
the true tragedy of his fate at least
until the right jedi came along to give
him hope again check out one of our
newest videos right here plus even more
looper videos about star wars are coming
soon subscribe to our youtube channel
and hit the bell so you don't miss a
single one